last week a group led by walmart heir
rob walton won the bidding war for the
denver broncos nfl team with a 4.65
billion dollar offer the deal is the
most expensive sports team purchase in
history and brought a lot of attention
to the typically low profile rob walton
the eldest son of walmart founder sam
walton he inherited his fortune and
served as walmart's chairman for 23
years now worth 57.2 billion dollars he
is the 15th richest person in america
and the fifth richest u.s heir
tremendous family wealth is a hallmark
of the forbes list of the country's
richest people though many billionaire
heirs hail from a handful of companies
one such company is agriculture giant
cargill the largest private company in
the country which has propelled 12 heirs
into the three comma club the
great-grandchildren and
great-great-grandchildren of founder w w
cargill still own almost 90 percent of
the business he founded in 1865.
due to ties there are 23 people in the
top 20 of america's richest billionaire
heirs and they're worth an estimated 568
billion dollars altogether that's about
13.5 percent of the 4.2 trillion dollars
in wealth of all 701 u.s billionaires
according to forbes estimates tied at
number one are charles and julia coke
worth 59.6 billion dollars respectively
their fortunes come from koch industries
which charles and his late brother david
inherited from their father fred the
brothers grew it into the second largest
private company in the u.s with an
estimated 115 billion dollars in
revenues julia david's widow and her
three children inherited david's 42
stake in koch industries when he died in
2019
walton airs jim alice and rob walton
round out the top five they're worth
58.3 billion dollars 57.5 billion
dollars and 57.2 billion dollars
respectively and draw all their wealth
from the big box retail store founded by
their father mackenzie scott comes in at
number six with a net worth of 30.7
billion dollars scott formerly known as
mackenzie bezos became a billionaire in
2019 when amazon founder jeff bezos
transferred her a quarter of his 78.8
million amazon shares as a part of their
divorce settlement one of the largest in
history
tied at number seven are john and
jacqueline mars worth 29.7 billion
dollars each john and jacqueline both
inherited a third of the candy firm mars
after their father forrest marsh senior
died in 1999. at number nine is miriam
adelson worth 25.1 billion dollars
adelson inherited her late husband
sheldon's gambling empire after he died
in january 2021. the 76 year old owns 52
percent of the new york stock exchange
listed las vegas sands which has casinos
in singapore and macau and rounding out
the top 10 is leonard lotter worth 20.7
billion dollars lotter owns about 20
percent of the cosmetics giant estee
lauder founded in 1946 by his parents
estee and joseph lauder he ran the
company as ceo for more than three
decades taking it public in 1995 before
stepping down from that role in 1999
you